bonjour romain vidal merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france
j'imagine que vous attendait beaucoup de
cette réunion ce soir avec entre
emmanuel macron et ses ministres est ce
que vous avez la profession en tout cas
déjà rencontrer l'exécutif pour parler
de ces protocoles de réouverture oui oui
tout à fait bonjour tout le monde
nos organisations professionnelles ont
eu et ont pu rencontrer les équipes le
gouvernement début mars pour commencer
les discussions avec les premières
esquisses d'un plan de réouverture qui
se déroule en trois étapes
on a demandé dès le départ une une
visibilité pour pouvoir s'organiser car
c'est vrai qu'on est quand même beaucoup
entre guillemets rodez pour la
réouverture de nos terrasses puisque
c'est une pâle photocopies
malheureusement pour nous de 2020 où on
travaillera au départ qu'avec nos
terrasses et un protocole sanitaire qui
se doit d'être le même parce que
autrement on pourrait pas ouvrir ça
serait une ouverture à perte
donc ça c'est là la première étape si je
puis dire au 15 mai vous y croyez il
faut y croire alors le 17 mai c'est plus
un radis
il faut y croire en espérant puisque le
les taps le plan s'organise en trois
étapes
le gouvernement demande quatre semaines
pour chaque étape ce qui est un petit
peu long parce que ça nous ferait ouvert
ouvrir définitivement mi juillet
ce qui serait ta pour beaucoup de monde
nous on demande deux semaines il faut y
croire tout dépend comment on va
s'organiser on sait que le protocole
sanitaire est appliquée dans la plupart
de nos restaurants il a fait ses preuves
on a bien vu que pendant le dernier
confinement on était fermés ça rien
changé et les gens ont hâte de retrouver
et nous on peut les cadres et donc dans
nos terrasses on sera là il faut bien
sûr être vigilant pour nous que les
clients soient vigilants et si jamais il
ya des débordements que le gouvernement
agisse sur les personnes qui se font les
débordements vous dites que ça tient au
respect des protocoles ça tient surtout
à la situation tendue dans les hôpitaux
vous pensez pas qu emmanuel macron va y
mettre des bémols
depuis le départ on disait qu'à
l'extérieur on risquait pas grand chose
là on parle de l'ouverture que des
terrasses donc pas de l'intérieur avec
un protocole sanitaire des tables
distendus
et je pense que les français risquent
plus à manger un sandwich dans leurs
bureaux que de manger un sandwich en
plein air ou de manger un bon plat chez
nous dans une table qui permet d'avoir
de la place le seul 1 des conforts qu'on
pourra offrir nos couleurs telles
malheureusement c'est la place puisqu'on
va devoir admettre beaucoup de place
entre chaque client les français
resteront moins chez nous certainement
que au bureau ou chez eux les sauveurs
du monde
effectivement les scientifiques disent
que en extérieur c'est même pas
préconisé de mettre un masque puisque
les contaminations sont très rares quand
vous voyez ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire que vous avez vu les images
évidemment tout le monde a vu qu'on
avait vous pensez qu'il me tardait moi
aussi d'aller boire une bière en
terrasse
car même si je travaille je suis aussi
consommateurs donc il me tarde de
pouvoir retrouver ma clientèle de pas en
retrouver la vie de paris les terrasses
de paris qui sont connus mondialement
malheureusement sans touristes cette
année donc il va falloir qu'on puisse
retrouver la vie à travers nos habitués
nous les français les et les les
consommateurs qu on se met tous ensemble
autour des tables et qu'on en fait sur
ces retrouvailles pour justement avoir
de la place et est respecté les
distances est ce que les élus aussi les
élus locaux sont sollicités pour pouvoir
mettre à disposition un peu plus
d'espacé sur la sur la voie publique
alors on ne parle pas encore de cela
pour 2021
à paris par exemple on avait une
extension de terrasses qui s'étaient
prolongées jusqu'au début de l'été
normalement bon malheureusement on a été
fermée quasiment toute la durée de cette
de cette période là on espère avoir des
discussions prochainement avec certaines
grandes villes avec la plupart du temps
ils sont plutôt ouverts
il faut bien sûr faire attention
débordements mais la plupart du temps
quand c'est fait par des professionnels
et dans un bois où aucun encadrement
c'est très bien vu par les clients et
par le quartier parce que cela à nîmes
avant un commerce fermé pendant huit
mois en bas de chez soi c'est quelque
chose qui est pas agréable pour le vix
rom personnellement et au moins c'est
sécurisé de pouvoir savoir qu'il ya de
la vie en bas de chez soi
donc pour l'instant la perspective de
réouverture à l'intérieur des
restaurants est exclu c'est l'étape
numéro deux alors l'étape numéro deux
avec une jauge un protocole sanitaire
tout ça ne peut se faire bien entendu
que si
le protocole n'est pas plus dur et que
le juge ne soit pas trop dure parce que
malheureusement on sait qu'on va
travailler avec 50% une affaire n'est
pas viable avec 50% son chiffre
d'affaires la plupart du temps donc il
va falloir accompagner cette réouverture
qui est très limité quand même notamment
pour pouvoir sauvegarder notre emploi
continuer l'activité partielle le
chômage partiel comme l'appellent
certains parce que malheureusement
pourra pas reprendre bien sûr toutes nos
effectifs avec 50 % d'activité
c'est impossible et clairement là si la
date du 15 mai les n'est pas respectée
et que c'est reporter encore quelle
serait la situation des restaurateurs
beaucoup mettre la clé sous la porte
pour l'instant nous avons d un bel
accompagnement quand même du
gouvernement même s'il a quand même ses
limites pour les groupes de taille
moyenne et les plus gros groupes on va
dire en sachant que certains
établissements dans des grandes villes
avec le poids immobiliers sont tout de
suite des établissements moyens aux gros
même si c'est qu'un seul établissement
on est on est quand même aidé à être
fermé mais c'est compliqué beaucoup
perdre de l'argent chaque mois donc on
vit avec la volonté de pouvoir
retravailler
on est on est on vit pas pour pouvoir
rester chez soi et attendre que ça se
passe donc on attendra peut-être au 1er
juin
s'il faut offrir le premier gens et on
ouvrira le premier genre et spectra les
décisions du gouvernement
mais il faut vraiment qu'on ait un plan
de d'accompagnement et pas que jusqu'à
la réouverture bien au delà parce que la
crise va durer économiquement pour nos
restaurants qui ont connu parce qu'une
année de fermeture et malheureusement
paris et les grandes villes n'ont aucun
touriste et cet été il n'y aura aucun
parisien tout le monde partira en
vacances donc il faut prévoir cet
accompagnement c'est urgent et c'est
très important
clairement romain vidal vous demandez
une date ce soir au président de la
république
c'est bien d'avoir une date ça nous
permet de nous préparer de d'avoir un
point étape même si sa dette est
repoussée parce que malheureusement il y
aurait quelques uns
à une crise sanitaire supplémentaires
une nouvelle vague chose qu'on pourrait
bien entendu comprendre encore une fois
cette crise ne serait pas de notre faute
puisqu'on est fermé mais on pourrait la
comprendre mais avoir une date ça permet
de réunir ses équipes et de préparer
passe finalement j'ai fait venir mais
équipe aujourd'hui hors de cuisine pour
commencer à discuter de la nouvelle
carte restaurant et je fais venir mais
équipe de salle la semaine prochaine
pour commencer à faire un emploi du
temps et voir avec eux comment ils
veulent reprendre le travail
donc c'est important d'avoir une date
bien sûr merci beaucoup romain vidal
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france merci